[Music]
and believe in the youth news
I do pound are they stupid as [ __ ]
there's a future great I do not trust
myself I thought I knew about the world
when I was 14 I was like man people are
so stupid why don't they just do this
and change the world
yeah even when I was like 23 I had like
so many ideas and like why is it like
that I'm like oh I get it yeah I get it
now
yup that's why I think 90 year olds
should rule the world
they're too tired they're like [ __ ] it
let's blow it up I don't feel like a
year and then what happens we'll have
mandatory life in Medicare or whatever I
want to wake them up every two hours
submitted by daily special oh I love the
day special Stephen King is allowing
teenage film students to have their
rights to his stories for just one
dollar whoa did you like like theater
plays or something like that oh yeah
so these $1 front or like stories that
he's giving away for a dollar
it's called dollar babies and as this
section of Stephen King's official
website and it allows film students to
request the rights for a selection of
for like one of the selection of his
short story so they can adapt it in
their own way
hey that's awesome that is really cool
and you have to be a team a team you
have to be a student
yeah a film student so you could be a
film soon in college I'm assuming it
been by one of his stories $4 and then
make millions
no no that's part of the contract you
cannot make money
oh you can't and he'd take it back and
make money I'm site for your resume guys
yeah thanks for that your portfolio
I see it's exactly for that and it also
gives confidence to these students
because they're like I worked on the
Stephen King don't kids just do it for
free and just take people's stories and
like anyway yeah cuz if they're not
gonna sell it I don't know but it has a
Simmons King name on it oh sorry
we had exactly carry a lot of weight
mm-hmm so he's like written by Stephen
King cuz I think a lot of them write
their own thesis films because I used to
audition for student films and they were
real bad like with a lot of there's
always like a like a shot of water
running out of the sink or something
yeah yeah but then the dialogue is just
like I don't you don't talk like that
that's true yeah so now there are these
students these teenage students in the
UK in Wales that they're now gonna be
working on one of Stephen King's stories
which it's called stationary bike
follows an artist who's told he has
dangerously high cholesterol so when he
began cycling to lose weight he becomes
obsessed and begins to hallucinate
nightmarish scenarios damn this who
knows how to make everything scare lose
some weight cuz I'm fat and he makes
that scary like weight loss that is
crazy
I've been watching this new thing that
he created it's on
[ __ ] you Hulu or Amazon but it's it's
called castle rock - it's crazy Castle
Rock so you know that uh that jail
Shawshank ya out in um like that area he
does Josh's Redemption did he no no I
don't know but it's a jail called
Shawshank and then the the the idea is
that there is the devil there's a devil
that was a kind of what do you call it
the took took form of a human boy and
then the jailer thought that what he had
to do was grab this devil boy and then
hide him in that Jail and then like he
commits suicide and and later like they
find this kid sounds like some other
story yeah and then like they don't know
what to do with them and then like I
don't know it's pretty nuts but it's it
gets crazier and crazier I like it it's
pretty awesome
and they kid is a devil but the devil
boy or that you can't ruin it okay yeah
I can't see that's the thing but it
makes you question though like death
right was his name Damien no I don't
remember was that the omen yeah my mom
thought I was the devil boy yeah you
were that bad I have been I was that bad
but to my mom Shawshank Redemption it
was yeah no that's awesome I love that
movie really I'm surprised I just
googled it uh Rita Hayworth and
Shawshank Redemption why is he so
obsessed with the Shawshank Jail
maybe a lot of crazy well they don't
know their life but it wasn't even
dancing did he invent that Jill
Shanker's are a real jail called
swashing let me google this yeah check
if there's a shot saw Shawshank Jail
hey check why chick-fil-a aren't open on
Sundays I know why that's cuz the
Christian is about to open on Sunday are
they Christian they're not that
Christian would be a real place
Christian but we like this money so come
they're like we'll just put Bible verses
on like secret parts of our you know
yeah like if you look at the bottom of
the cup it says like John 3:16 or some
[ __ ] like that maybe that was just the
owner of it Oh John and it's his
birthday
yeah like this favorite time the
fictional New England state prison Oh
see they got me to believe it actually
exists that means he's good at writing
yo it was like one day I'm gonna go to
Shawshank and he is devil boy I know
right like and then I'm gonna go to that
house with all the balloons that flew in
the sky yeah you know there's really
enough house what just recently it's
modeled off of a real house like there's
this couple that really built it because
it all they built it after the movie
yeah Oh a fly no but it's like in
somewhere in California a North house
does I have the balloons no yeah but it
is like penis is not the up now
yeah these are a grumpy old man that
lives there like it felt like the
furniture the architectural and
generally the up house they need the
balloons but the balloons who is what
like but they do it after it's not that
I guess anymore not the up house but
imagine how many times they would have
to refill those balloons how often they
would have to put fake plastic ones that
they put at the car dealership where it
like stays with the stickers just a fake
one so it looks like lollipops you gotta
like that that's pretty cool how crazy
do you have to be to be able to create
this much scary [ __ ] through your brain
look at Rob Zombie man that fools head
is wild it's an outlet Marilyn Monroe
dress is the winner do you think it's
real or do you think it's just for show
like a moat it's like a carrot like
their characters likes to Stephen King
really [ __ ] though
no but Cena can literally have like
hundreds of books I used to work up
orders the bookstore yeah yeah alright
bookshelf of Justice stuff he still
keeps creating how old is he unlimited
unlimited amounts of just [ __ ]
murderous crazy scary [ __ ] maybe that's
what prevents him from doing actual [ __ ]
71 years old all this fun he's doing a
lifetime of scary
that's his brain what's his favorite
food a lot of people they like to like
have an outlet right and then once they
get it out are you know like imagine
it's just like pasta rolling like you
know I'm going to do MMA and stuff like
when you're training like you get all
that aggression up and then some of the
finest times I have is after their
trainer ah just chill and we're just
like yay
it's all fine it's not like if this fool
wrote all that aggression out is he only
eating cotton candy every day buddy
double like writes about demons in which
that's so normal in his life though yeah
[ __ ] do you have to go through cuz like
imagine writing a letter to your husband
for example like after the third happy
birthday letter you're like alright I
told you everything I feel for you like
that you like you just keep something
like yeah that's what I'm thinking it
feels better every year my cards get
better
that's a scary spot really yeah that's
true I imagine him like going into his
riders meetings and it's like zombies
again
can you see no that's why you've got to
write about stationary bikes he's like
oh yeah wow that is like that is
next-level though cuz he's like hot like
killing imma talk about pillow [ __ ] like
let's [ __ ] up comfortable [ __ ] up
because you know your own bed going
class no one will tell you that movie
the ring I put it look at TVs at night
Oh in my room like was that Stephen King
that's a Japanese thing talking about
making stuff in your home you know after
the ring I got scared of taking showers
long black hair was never the same
I had long black hair they're scared of
yourself no that's not that movie is the
theaters three times and they've each
time I win I still have a wash I knew
she was about to pop out I put my hair
here and I was like yes and I was with a
big yeah I used to do an impression over
here fret and it would be like I made
the sound effect I think scary a movie
where they parodied it and then the
thing crawled out and then she was like
[Laughter]
yeah so is he married I want to be
married I know I need answers just be
label yeah I'm really curious how this
creative process is let's go I want to
see what his house looks like the mic
does it look like a normal Oh that'd be
creepy else inside it's all white inside
that's like really believe angelic
looking I feel is married he's been
married since 1970 with his house looked
like a Home and Garden magazine like
super Martha Stewart II yeah with
[ __ ] to look like can we see I don't
have a father
what is why do you want to make fun of
her to have her name is cut it's like
it's Tabitha it's like one of those like
you know in the story that you hear
about like he probably wrote her to make
the Victorian times alright as though
she looks like I picture his wife to
look like Elvira she was fine as [ __ ]
dude
Oh Myra oh yeah dude her dress and her
[ __ ] TV who's the other one the the
Munsters mom yeah like they're all kind
of like that same look and there's
another one the vampire
yeah and she was like yeah no that wait
yeah so this is what did it yeah his
wife Oh
[Music]